a question I often get is are there
issues where I've changed my mind or
maybe disagree with the progressive
Orthodoxy and I've talked about GMO
genetically modified foods and at some
point I just generally thought they were
probably bad for human health and it
turns out there's not actually evidence
of that and so I've changed my mind on
that and when it comes up and I have the
opportunity I will talk about it the
other is new nuclear power nuclear power
is something that for understandable
historical reasons there are people on
the left who are reflexively against it
but the more I actually learned about it
the more I found out that relative to
energy production nuclear power even
historically is very safe and that new
nuclear power not only doesn't not only
avoid some of the biggest issues with
burning fossil fuels like air pollution
and Etc but from a political standpoint
it's actually also very interesting in
terms of foreign policy and sovereignty
and Independence and so my view there
has changed as well and it turns out
many people aren't aware that 20 of
American households get energy from
nuclear power there are those on the
left who have safety concerns about
nuclear but I have found that many of
those concerns are outdated and they're
based on issues from 40 years ago and
where I'm finding that a lot of the
attitudes and arguments
haven't caught up with the new
advancements of nuclear safety and
sometimes even how nuclear even works
it's really an opportunity to have an
interesting conversation about nuclear
power and there are many upsides it is
reliable
it's cost effective it's one of the
lowest impact energy sources in terms of
carbon
it may be a necessary step in solving
the energy gap and responding to climate
change and that's increasingly
increasingly the position of many
Democrats as well which I'm actually
pleased to see but the problem in the
U.S is we import all of the uranium that
we use for nuclear power that's a
national security issue since half of it
comes from Russia much of it from
Kazakhstan which is a Russian proxy the
two worst countries we could arguably be
relying on for a resource like this and
also the shipping component uses energy
and in particular fossil fuels so you're
sort of like circling back to more of
the same issue countries like Russia are
also responsible for much of the uranium
processing and the technology behind it
which is another opportunity for the US
the U.S having its own uranium industry
would have a number of benefits and
several Western European countries are
already taking steps to to do this but
if you're someone looking at uranium
what it's becoming the benefits of not
relying on other countries you may also
see it as an opportunity for investment
it's not quite so simple
with other Commodities you can buy the
underlying commodity on a market you
just can't do that with uranium but
there could be an interesting Way
Forward as far as that goes in January
2020 the first ever and only company to
offer uranium royalties went public and
that's uranium royalty Corp u-r-o-y on
NASDAQ you Roy and they've partnered
with us on this video they don't spend
any money drilling or developing or
mining or extracting or refining or
hauling these are just folks that have
knowledge and experience with the
financial side of the industry it's like
a record company buying a music catalog
and collecting royalties and what you
Roy does
is they acquire and create royalty
agreements it's that simple they own a
portfolio of 15 royalties two of them
already are gearing up for production to
generate royalties and uroy with their
uranium managerial experience will
acquire and store physical uranium in
drums they currently have a million and
a half pounds on their balance sheet
they'll keep adding more they'll take
Supply off the market and they will
physically back you Roy with that supply
and they have 127 million in cash as of
August of this year these types of
funding vehicles are necessary if the
industry is going to be established
imagine that a brand new country is
created they have no roads and you own
the company that will build the roads
and charge for the tolls for using them
and it's the only player in the market
what you have here is the only Boutique
funding for new uranium and for buying
physical Supply no other place to find
it I've been following you Roy for a
while I've been excited about doing this
video with them uranium is really
something that I believe we're going to
see more of in the news over the next
decade like with many of these issues
um we shouldn't let the perfect become
the enemy of the good
and we should try to avoid partisan
blindness or being blinded bipartisan
preconceived notions we're going to see
more uranium the relationship with
Russia is a major factor the U.S and
Western countries have to figure out a
way to become independent with nuclear
energy if that's the direction things
are going to go and at some point it's
going to happen I think it's going to be
sooner than later so you Roy is unique
it's timely they have an interesting
approach they're in the front row in the
driver's seat and I would invite you to
check out more about you Roy using the
link below check out more about new
nuclear power as well and just as a
reminder nothing in this video is
financial advice and everyone should
always do their own due diligence in
advance of any financial decision